whether you realize it or not you have a
personal brand if I looked you up on
Google and didn't find anything about
you on the first page of results that's
your personal brand if I found an
out-of-date LinkedIn profile or a bunch
of random social media posts that too is
your personal brand
[Music]
a personal brand as bragging
self-promotion and all about yourself
but it's actually something much more
important it's your reputation in other
words it's how people perceive you your
friends colleagues are the general
public and it's what people think about
you when they hear your name as well as
what people say about you when you're
not in the room in our connected world
every single one of us has a personal
brand whether we like it or not this is
because whenever we engage with people
both in person and online that's every
interaction or everything we post upload
or comment on we're creating a
reputational narrative about ourselves
your reputation is already out there the
question is do you want to be the one
who's driving and shaping the story or
do you want chants or algorithms to be
doing it for you I think most people
would agree that they want to take
control and what this means is we need
to make some very intentional decisions
so our brand stays in our hands let me
walk you through five key steps to build
being a strong personal brand in a way
that feels good first you need to figure
out what your goal is let's start by
answering a foundational question what
do you want your personal brand to help
you accomplish are you looking to change
jobs or transition into a new industry
and you need your brand to reflect a new
skill set maybe you're looking to get a
promotion at your current organization
and you need everyone to know all the
amazing things that you've accomplished
in your career or maybe you're launching
a new business and you want to build
your brand around the products or
services that you're offering whatever
your goal is write it down and make it
specific so that you're working towards
a clear outcome next you'll want to get
clear on what you want to be known for
in other words how do you want people to
describe you as a professional start by
answering the question so what do you do
and I'm not just talking about your job
title are you a teacher who focuses on
social and emotional learning or maybe
you're a project manager who is reliable
and always gets things done on time or
maybe you're an artist who makes
beautiful ceramic pots from natural
materials what you want to do is dig
deeper into the what how and why behind
your work so you can make it concrete
and easy to remember just make sure to
lead with something that doesn't cause
confusion for example I once coached
someone who called herself a deaf
Midwife which no one understood but when
she started introducing herself as a
grief counselor who works with families
during a time of loss all of a sudden
everyone got it if you're stumped think
about how you can stand out from the
crowd in your industry what are the
things that make you unique Are there
specific talents and expertise that
you've acquired in your career
what do you know more about than most
people
sit down and make a list and you might
start to surprise yourself about all the
things you know now let's think about
the audience you want to share your
personal brand with the reality is your
personal brand is not about you it's
about the people you want to educate
with the skills knowledge and value you
can provide who you decide to focus on
should be based on two things the goal
of your personal brand and the people
who can best benefit from your unique
talents and skills so spend some time
thinking about these two questions who
can most gain from what you have to
share and how exactly can you see
yourself helping them here's where it
all starts to come together let's pull
all your answers into a single mission
statement that describes who you are
what you do who you do it for and the
transformation you can create in
people's lives let's take the example of
the teacher my name is Alma and I'm a
third grade teacher who specializes in
Social and emotional learning I work
with students to teach them the skills
for fostering empathy and compassion so
they can Thrive and contribute to a more
caring world let's take the project
manager my name is Jennifer and I'm a
project manager for sustainable fashion
company
I work with teams across different
departments to plan organize and direct
Innovative marketing campaigns that
engage customers while also increasing
brand loyalty mission statements are
going to look wildly different depending
on who you are in your career but
whatever your mission statement is write
it down and put it somewhere prominent
you can use it to make decisions about
how you speak about yourself when you
first meet someone to the communities
you want to share it with let's start
building a personal brand online there
are two key personal branding assets you
should think about developing a personal
website and social media what's so
important about a personal website is
that it allows you to take full control
over your online reputation it offers
the most flexibility in sharing your
brand and value to others in a much
deeper way than a resume or LinkedIn
profile people want to work with others
they like know and trust and your
personal website provides you an
opportunity to share more about your
personality through photos as well as
more about your career and life story
this in turn will differentiate you from
others in your industry social media is
also a great way to share your personal
brand with the audience you're looking
to connect with however I suggest trying
not to be on every platform pick one
that aligns with your goals as well as
where your audience spends most of its
time if you're an artist or creative
Instagram is a great fit if you work in
a more corporate environment LinkedIn is
the place you want to be when posting
focus on being helpful to others share
interesting articles relevant to your
industry post ideas or opinions that can
benefit colleagues and like or comment
on posts shared by the people you follow
the key is to always engage in a way
that both reinforces your personal brand
while also bringing value to others look
I know this may all sound a bit
intimidating but try to think of this
branding process as an opportunity for
personal growth it's your chance to dig
deeper into who you truly are and who
you want to become this in turn will
provide you the clarity you need I and
how you can make your greatest impact in
the world